I'm not trying to see no [ __ ] like
7-foot person Bowl mm-hmm I told me get
the [ __ ] out even if it was a really
good boy who was Khalifa Wiz Khalifa
he's an amazing bowler amazing if you
want to see amazing bowler
why is he bull rappers bow him I don't
know I thought bowling was like an old
white person sport or like TV on ESPN it
looks like it yeah like a Korean turtle
when you go for yourself you know you
see them yeah and by them I mean rappers
what the [ __ ] I didn't know rappers Bowl
yeah man like him up he's doing this is
a Khalifa bowling Wiz Khalifa him and
his whole Taylor Gang they got two pins
in Studio City
what yeah every Wednesday night and they
Bowl yo first video that pops up pins
feet Taylor gay Dodie told you what the
[ __ ] of this fool does muy Thai any
balls yeah I was like yo Jabril cuz this
is really oh really my name is Khalif oh
[ __ ] you bulb yeah he's like ha Turkey
today ha ha ha Chevy Woods get this
there you said what's up to him is he
really nice he's super nice you're
actually really good at that when you
see a celebrity you're actually not
afraid to say hi I'm Matt I don't know
yeah some people and you don't do it in
a very obnoxious way you just say hi
tell them you know you [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] yeah go about your way I can't do
it I get weirded [ __ ] yeah well it was
less something happen to you Ania long
no just right I saw the alum and I held
hand extra long I did I was at Sundance
and I saw near long and I shook her head
and I said I masturbated to you so much
of the kid you have no idea
no but I definitely did masturbate to
kneel on Oh a hundred percent dude knee
long as bad as [ __ ] she's still bad man
she's definitely bad yeah like I held
her head I did that to people I did that
to Tatiana Ali I announced it to Nia
Long who surprised and they look like
they could be related yeah but I help
Tatiana lose your hand super [ __ ]
long and I just didn't say anything
what was that this was that a it was
that a club event or some [ __ ] like that
oh I'll go because she has like a
agent ID for like Asian dudes or some
[ __ ] but she's friends with a couple of
my friends stereotypes stereotypes you
know not saying I'm saying like we
always do stuff but you know check back
for ya if you do some YouTube search you
know if you do a you to you see with the
stereotypes no but they're really dope
dudes and they're friends with Tatyana
Ali and John Street he introduced me to
attend Tatiana Ali and all I could think
about was Ashley banks and I just just
that yeah yo you remember when Tatyana
Ali had a single oh yeah they German
dude remix yeah man oh dude I I forgot
the second song on that single was her
oh she was on a sailboat looking hella
sexy though I remember the music video I
don't know in the music video
damn I'm going down memory lane now you
know buried in Tatiana Lena what if I
say the lyrics right now could you sing
it
no all day long I think of you I can't
even think of things to do
wishing all of my day dreams come true
no I can't
don't number it all I think it about but
down every night talking but that's not
that that's not a song what a Sunday
Deering no what the [ __ ]
that's a different song yeah but that's
what it sounds like uh-uh yes Africa her
second single was she had a second
single yeah dude well Tatiana leet was a
[ __ ] though yeah I was thinking of Maya
yeah he masturbated to Maya
you know we're gonna have to wait for
Cisco to get off the stage to their
music video and it's just hurting like
Chinese robe the other leg would show
out a light damn it's kind of weird when
you kind of jack off to the side he's
anything you see them in person
the other person not gonna be more as an
adult I absolutely do
Herman this [ __ ] [ __ ] uh what's it
called uh Tyra Banks we saw Tyra Baker
your barbecue yeah I'm glad you said it
cuz I did she was she was my first nut
[Laughter]
do you remember the first time I was
like I must have been 12 11 12 13 that
was your first nut yeah because I
remember I had like the college rule
bound notebook and I will cut pictures
at our bank and glue them into this
notebook and just look at him and she
had this one photo of her in a pink
bikini on the swimsuit edition I know
you don't remember this one of course it
was yeah that is fun and i splooged all
right you kids don't even know how
[ __ ] lucky you are do you have any
idea it took for us to masturbate the
women we had this [ __ ] I had the
[ __ ] the children's scissors but what
that you can't cut your skin all that
Hannity DOMA cut and he had to cut that
[ __ ] out and he was so ashamed of
himself he putted it into a notebook so
it looks like he's studying exactly
that's exactly my game plan and then he
opened this [ __ ] up and he whacked off
to Tyra Banks and a cutout of a notebook
yeah that's how hard it was you guys
have been so lucky you just go on Google
right now you look a pie recipe and a
[ __ ] comes out so what are you doing in
Utah over the new year Utah just like
playing pickleball [ __ ] is